prime minister
i would like to welcome you to this
parliament
i would like to welcome prime minister
andrei plenkovic with us today prime
minister welcome back
to the european parliament
a house that you know so well we know
you as a proud
pro-european
who was a state secretary for european
integration
laid the groundwork for croatia's
accession to the european union in 2013
and as a member of the european
parliament you worked closely with all
of us and also our ukrainian colleagues
and today
it is under your leadership as prime
minister of
croatia that your country
has successfully met all the legal
criteria for entry into the euro area
congratulations
at the start of the year our house
celebrated the euro's 20th anniversary
and it is fitting therefore that croatia
will soon become the 20th member of the
eurozone and this marks at a true
defining moment for croatia and our
union
but in order to remain
uh credible we must also be consistent
croatia is ready for schengen the
european parliament has long recognized
that croatia has met all the necessary
requirements to join the schengen area
and we will continue to support that
croatia's european story is a success
story it gives hope
it shows results with a war on our
continent with the decisions that we
must take this week
the importance of hope cannot be
underestimated
but hope alone will only get us so far
with when countries look to europe they
expect us to keep our promises and they
expect tangible progress because europe
can be more and on that note i thank you
prime minister dear andre thank you for
being a staunch supporter of europe for
your leadership and for your tireless
endeavors to maintain a viable eu
perspective for the region prime
minister andre the floor is yours
[Music]
honorable president of the european
parliament the roberta
honorable vice president's leaders of
political groups
honorable members i may even say dear
friends and dear colleagues
honorable vice president of the european
commission dear dubai
dear citizens of croatia dear citizens
of the european union's member states
it is my great pleasure to speak in
front of you here in the european
parliament already for the third time
during my six years as the prime
minister of croatia
but also it is my pleasure to be here
with you
as a friend as a former colleague or
that was here between 2013 and 2016
and also i would like to remember my
friend david sasoli
who was a president of the european
parliament and who unfortunately
left us too early
almost half a year ago
this was a great loss for
his family but also to his home country
in italy and to the entire
european union
dear friends when i was speaking last
time here in this
house of european democracy
i presented at the time it was january
2020 the program of the first ever
croatia's presidency of the council of
the european union
the title of this program was a strong
europe in the world of challenges
what unfolded literally two weeks after
that speech
was the
breakout of a covet 19 pandemic
an event that has entirely altered the
way
of our lives the way of our work of our
business of our transport of our
education
it has literally
altered the decision-making process
the way we used to know it in the
european union
croatia's presidency couldn't have
guessed better that the world was really
facing a challenge
and the challenge was the biggest
pandemic in 100 years
the challenge that
made us be creative
the challenge that has demonstrated more
togetherness among the eu member states
the challenge that has shown the
unprecedented solidarity
and the incredible swiftness and
efficiency in our common actions to
protect our citizens from this plague
that has hit the world and that has hit
the european union that has threatened
the lives of our citizens
and in that respect i think we can now
uh looking back at what was done in such
a short period of time
not only with epidemiological measures
with the provision of protective
equipment but the
incredibly fast discovery of the
vaccines
we can say that we
saved jobs
that we have kept
the existential needs of our families
that we have managed to help our
companies our businesses especially in
the private sector
to bridge the threats
that were that they were facing
in that respect
i as a prime minister
was conducted by the concept of our
policy which we call
the modern approach the modern take on
sovereignty
what it means to a country which became
internationally recognized only 30 years
ago
is important to understand
we were a nation
that was seeking its independence that
was seeking its state for many centuries
we finally attained
this
strategic national objective only 30
years ago in the context of tectonic
global change changes and the fall of
the berlin wall and the entire
fall of the communist regimes in the
eastern europe
and for us
attaining our sovereignty was very
important
having our own state was very important
but we have
very quickly decided that the future of
our nation belongs to the european union
and everything we have done for
two decades after we became
internationally recognized and the day
of our international international
recognition is the 15th of january
we strived to become member of the
european family
and we managed that in 2013
and when i say today to my fellow croats
modern take on sovereignism
that means that we are achieving our
national goals
by pulling and sharing guys our
sovereignty with our friends and
partners in the european union
that we are helping our citizens
with the extension
of the christian principle of solidarity
something that brings us together
something that helps us to overcome
all the difficulties and problems that
we would have otherwise
overcome in a far more complicated and
difficult and most likely slower manner
that's why this approach that we have
for our own
country
we are
systematically
advocating for the entire future of our
european union
because this debate comes in the context
of the series of debates on this is
europe
and i will say a few words about
the biggest challenge
the challenge that has started on the
24th of february this year
the brutal russian invasion and
aggression against ukraine
has
literally annihilated
the main principles of international law
the main
approach to the global governance to the
international relations
that we were cultivating for decades
the united nations
member country sovereign country
neighboring country
has
suffered a brutal aggression
for croatia who was also a victim of
aggression of at the time greater
serbian policy
by milosevic regime at the beginning of
the 90s
it was very
quick spontaneous almost a reflex
reaction
of first of all understanding what was
going on in ukraine
and second
in extending our support and help
the policy of moscow
has two elements it has two sticks
one stick is the nuclear arsenal the
other stick
are the fossil fuels
with these two sticks
they
were able
to conduct such an aggression against
ukraine
at the same time the two natives the
narrative of
literally not recognizing
the ukrainian identity if you say that
you're not ukrainians but you are small
russians then you go into the essence of
the identity of a nation
and second the almost incredible
narrative of the nazification of ukraine
was
in our view quickly translated into
similar type of narratives that we had
in 1990 vis-a-vis the croats
almost the same
when it comes to the identity
and when it comes to the so-called
denatification
and these parallels were very clear to
us
in my speech at the european council on
the 24th of february i said that this
has happened
in the moment where
obviously the analysis in moscow was
that there were some weaknesses
in the context of the timing of the
state of play of the west i will put it
in general
the first one was the way of perception
that the
west
left
afghanistan
perhaps not in the most dignified manner
the second
was the fact that there was a
change of era in political terms in
germany
second was that france was preoccupied
with
presidency of the council
and the presidential and then of course
which we witnessed recently
parliamentary elections third
the united kingdom left out its own
reasoning the european family
all of this happened immediately just as
in 2008 when they were the mandeville
olympic games
in beijing at the time there were summer
olympic claims and there was an invasion
of georgia now it happened again after
the olympic games again in beijing
winter olympic games it happened in
ukraine
what were the ramifications
ramifications for ukrainian nation
are devastating
tens of thousands of dead
civilians and soldiers 13 million people
displaced 6 million refugees
incredible material destruction
and the occupation of territory
but what we have witnessed was the
incredible mobilization
of the international community and
support for ukraine
we did the same we paid our contribution
with a lot of heart both in political in
diplomatic in economic in financial
terms in humanitarian terms by hosting
the refugees in our country there are
over 20 000 ukrainians which
found shelter in croatia and we are
ready to receive them more
and of course we help them just as many
other members of the european union
by
providing them means to fight for their
freedom for their independence for their
lives and that was the procurement of
military aid
in that context ukraine applied for the
membership in the european union
i was one of the
members of the european council who was
immediately very clear and articulate
about supporting this candidacy not only
because i was the president of the
delegation for relations with ukraine
when i was an mep here
several years ago but because i know
how important
this gesture in this context for
ukrainian leadership but most of all for
the ukrainian nation and ukrainian
people is
and therefore i'm pleased to see that
the position
of many member states is now
being assembled around the wording that
will
most likely the historic european
council tomorrow and on friday actually
grant ukraine the candidate status
i think this is important it's
courageous
and it is certainly deserved by a nation
that is fighting for the european
principles
of freedom
and of democracy
and therefore our support to ukraine
will remain very clear
and unwavered
similarly we support the candidate
status for moldova we support the
candidate status for georgia with
conditions we feel that this
great leap of putting all of those three
countries into the context of those
states at the european continent who do
have a european perspective
is an important political evolution
on the architecture of our europe and of
our continent so if this is debate on
europe this is a big change
on the way that we are looking at
countries who are not yet members of the
european union
in this context i will
just say that the global perception
of
the current state of play of
international relations is going to be
focused
on the rather simple notion
and that is not the cooperative way of
conducting international relations
but more conflictual way of
international relations whereby we shall
on one side have democracies and on the
other side the authoritarian regimes
this is the gist
of the historical moment that we are
going through
and this is where the european union
as
one of those who are at the peak of the
democratic standards globally should
have a leading role in
and doing the so-called political
pedagogy wherever we can of what is
actually at stake
the ramifications
are hitting
everyone now
of russia's aggression against ukraine
in terms of energy crisis
in terms of
spike of the prices of the raw materials
construction materials food
even risking famine especially in the
eastern part of africa but elsewhere
globally too
and
putting inflationary pressures
on our own member states
this is important to understand no one
is untouched by the
magnitude of this
first of all energy crisis but even more
deeper by the rise of the prices of food
and here just as we did in covet
where we had a huge unexpected problem
but we provided a very big and efficient
answer and the answer was powerful
the eu next generation was a bold
european answer of the european union of
today to the problem that was hitting
every single of our citizens
and therefore the
attempt which we are now doing with the
initiative after debates the european
council the commission has come up with
a re-power eu
was an important
gesture and the guidance of the
commission how we can organize ourselves
by
being true to the commitment which we
said in versailles we shall gradually
abandon
the fossil fuels coming from russia
in order to be able to do that
and still
being able to
organize secure supply of energy to our
economies into our households we need to
organize ourselves in terms of energy
grids
in the european union and that means
investments
both in gas pipelines in oil pipelines
in
liquefied natural gas terminals croatia
did its part of the homework already
before we have one lng terminal at the
island of kirk with a capacity of 2.9
billion cubic meters now we decided to
invest in it to upgrade it to 6.1
billion cubic meters
which would be enough not only for our
needs in terms of our economy and our
citizens and our industry of course but
also to the needs of our neighboring
neighboring straight states such as
slovenia bosnia and herzegovina hungary
similarly we use in the same way the
croatian adriatic pipeline which can
provide enough oil for hungary for
slovakia for serbia
a pipeline that can easily provide
enough for the refineries in our
neighborhood
that means that our geostrategic
position
as in
as one of the energy hubs at the energy
map of europe is something we should try
to
foster and strengthen in the
years which are ahead of us
talking about the
debate on this is europe and our debate
the european council
tomorrow and on friday and especially
the summit that
is organized tomorrow morning with the
western balkans
i will mention here again
the countries that are close to us which
we know well where we are supporting
their path towards the european union
their european perspective
especially bosnia and herzegovina with
whom
we share more than 1 000 kilometers of
border
where croats
people who are the same as croats in
croatia are one of the three constituent
peoples of bosnia and herzegovina
with which we have
tremendous economic exchange
we are the second investor in bosnia and
herzegovina and there are so many
linkages historic cultural economic
transport that bind us together
and we of course
have been in favor
of granting a candidate status also to
bosnia and herzegovina very clearly
because we feel
that this country should not be
the last wagon in the train of the
western balkans towards the european
union it would be a historical unjustice
and therefore we are one of those member
states who are advocating granting a
candidate status also to bosnia and
herzegovina
in which context we would like also the
urgent solution for
the changes to the electoral law which
would enable that we have fair and just
elections in bosnia and herzegovina
where all the three
where all the three constituent peoples
and especially croats are after the
elections represented as duly as they
should be as it was the letter and the
spirit of the dayton paris agreement
whose nx4 is the constitution of the
country and this position is very clear
it's a friendly position it's a good
neighborly position it's a position that
will help the european future of bosnia
and herzegovina and croatia will be the
one who will be the first one to support
it wholeheartedly and continuously
when it comes to the future of
europe and the debate after the
convention on the future of europe and
the conference in the future of europe
sorry i would here like to thank dubrav
kashowitza who is a croatian member of
the european commission and the vice
president for
demography and democracy
and i think that
she has done a great job that the
european parliament has done a great job
that national parliaments have
participated in this all-encompassing
and inclusive process
in bringing the european citizens more
closer to the european institutions but
more essentially
to the gist of the debate of what we can
do better together and how we can
fill perhaps those voids
in our
cooperation or how we can rectify some
elements that should be done better
from that respect i think that the
confidence on the future of europe
especially its conclusions
with the
suggestions and recommendations
are a very clear signal
of the european peoples of european
citizens from all of our member states
in croatia we had more than 250 events
on what
the european institutions should do
what would be our direction i was in
particular
pleased that there was a very very clear
signal that we should do more in terms
of mixed shared competencies when it
comes to health cooperation if there was
one lessons learned from the pandemic
and we were in the driving seat we had a
presidency
our ambassador here our permanent
representative triggered the
mechanisms at the beginning already at
the end of january in 2020 and then we
realized that actually this was an area
where the european union member states
should have more structured cooperation
more shared competencies
more competencies for the commission to
lead the processes which were done
in the crisis management
in such an efficient way as if
everything was planned and it wasn't so
i think that this message that came from
the recommendations
should certainly be taken into account
when it comes to this critical debate on
the decision-making process
when it comes to the issues of foreign
and security policy
i understand and fully
can have a good comprehension of what
the position of the european parliament
is and i read the resolution
here
when you sit in the position
of a member of the european parliament
and i'm lucky to have this experience
and when you sit in your position as a
head of government the optic is a little
bit different
there are perhaps
97 98 99 percent of the situations where
we find a compromise and agreement
almost on everything
occasionally there are situations
where
we differ
and we have sometimes difficulties
in
finding the understanding of other
partners for the particular position we
have
i'm always saying that
conditioning or blackmailing is a very
bad policy we were a victim of black
mailing for several years before we
became member and we don't like it and
we don't support it then we always
advocate how to use the right argument
with the right approach to our friends
to our partners we are all part of the
same family how we can reach a
compromise and i have noted
that many of the member states who
belong to let's say small and
medium-sized
member states are a little bit reticent
they're reticent because they know what
the mathematics and calculation of the
voting in the council means
and therefore i think that this issue
merits a very careful and a diligent
follow-up
and we shall enter into this debate we
shall take julie into account
the messages that were clearly sent to
us by the european conference and by the
resolution of the european parliament
may i say
a few
words
about the
croatia's
ambitions
in the in this almost
almost exactly ninth year of our
membership end of ninth year of our
membership because i think it's
important to
mention it as well
i conduct as a prime minister a very
pro-european policy taking into account
the national interest of my country just
as everybody else is doing and should do
and we decided in our program
six years ago that we want to be part of
two deeper integrations
two deeper integrations first one the
eurozone and
second the schengen area
and i was very pleased that roberta has
mentioned that the
croatia's
membership of the eurozone seems to be
set
your colleague siegfried morissand who i
would like to thank his rapporteur for
the croatian
membership in the eurozone
has after the visit to croatia made a
very
sober correct but also positively toned
report that the
relevant european parliament committee
has overwhelmingly supported
and i'm sure
the same happens
in the plenary
and that gesture of the european
parliament is highly appreciated in
croatia by my government by our citizens
and that means that after the
endorsement tomorrow at the european
council we are facing the final decision
at the echovin council on the 12th of
july
that means that croatia will join the
eurozone on the 1st of january 2023
just as we planned and just as we have
carefully and diligently implemented our
strategy for joining the euro the
program for the conversion of the
creation kona toyota the action plan
that followed after our joining of the
exchange rate mechanism 2 in the banking
union on the 10th of july 2020 five days
after
the second victory at the parliamentary
elections that we had
and that we shall fulfill this
key political first of all but also
economic and financial objective on time
and as we planned and i thank you for
your support and your understanding that
croatia becomes the 20th member of the
eurozone
at the same time
i think already next week the council
will send the formal proposal
uh for the decision to be taken
on the croatia's membership in the
schengen area also to the european
parliament where i expect we will
quickly have a rapporteur for
schengen
who will also take a very diligent view
on our readiness and we have also worked
very very hard to fulfill this criteria
where both junckers commissioned at the
end of their mandate in october 2019 and
then again commission of ursula from the
line and i would like to thank in
particular her and commissioner ilva
johansson have estimated that croatia
has fulfilled the necessary criteria and
that the relevant decision of the
council after the opinion of the
european parliament will be taken
in autumn and that we shall also join
this deeper integration on the 1st of
january 2023
that would mean that croatia
will be with all
with both
feet
firmly in the center of the european
union
firmly in the deeper integration thus
fulfilling
the
decision of the croatian parliament and
of the croatian people at the referendum
where we joined the european union
in that respect we shall strengthen our
economy we shall strengthen the free
movement we shall facilitate the free
movement of people
and it will be a backup
to a situation which we have today
we have the lowest number of unemployed
people in croatia in last perhaps 30
years
only 103 000
we have the biggest employment in
croatia in last 20 years and we shall
try to continue
intervening as i said many times
whether it was covered or now the energy
crisis to keep
the
economic
and social standard of our citizens
because this is clearly
a key priority which we will
make sure happens because of synergy of
using the european and croatian sources
the membership of the european union
has proved itself in time of crisis as
one of those essential tools how we can
fulfill the key national objectives and
provide shelter and security for our
citizens
in that respect i will mention one
important project also co-financed by
the european union budget means and that
is the palestinians bridge the bridge
that will be opened on the 26th of july
this year that will physically connect
the southern part of croatia with the
rest of the country for us it is a
strategic
objective that couldn't have had
more symbolic connotation that it has
and that we shall be continuing to
invest in the new security threats
into our defense capabilities
and into contribution of croatia to the
strategic autonomy of the european union
croatia will procure
12 french rafale
multi-combat planes that will arrive in
a little bit more than a year time from
today and that will strengthen our role
as a partner in the europe european
union's defense but also as a reliable
ally in nato all of this brings me to
conclusion
that the
times are full of challenges just as
much as we thought when we're preparing
our presidency program two and a half
years ago
but even more
when i look at the health crisis
security crisis political crisis
but also energy
and
existential crisis for many of our
citizens who without the role of the
state and moreover without a concerted
action joint action action through the
principle of solidarity of the european
union would not look for better future
as we can look at it today thank you
very much
[Music]
thank you
very much
thank you prime minister plenkovic and
now we have one round of representatives
of the political group starting with the
chair of the epp group with weber
president mitzola vice president switzer
and zefkovic
the prime minister andrei welcome
welcome back in the european parliament
as for my colleagues
and it's great to have you here
the second term now is prime minister
there's a strong mandate from your
citizens
you are leading croatia and you are also
leading the european debate
and
when i
have in mind that croatia is the
youngest member inside of the european
union today
it's impressive to see the european
success story behind her
when i look for these arguments for this
success story then
come first comes to my mind the
dramatically reduced youth unemployment
to give young generation a perspective
to reduce the demographic brain train
all these negative developments over the
last decades
and you mentioned already and also
roberta mentioned already two other
success stories which now joining the
euro zone
a big success and i want to underline
it's not only for croatia it's also for
europe for the eurozone a big success
because it's a proof that this makes
sense to do it together it strengthens
the authority of the euro in the world
and also now the schengen enlargement
you have the full support of your
political group and i think also from
the european parliament because you
managed to do the necessary steps
when we talk about the future of europe
croatia
is
there in a leading role i also want to
thank dubrevka for her service for her
work on the conference for the future of
europe
and you also referred to the history of
croatia and whenever i
speak about the general approach
creations towards the euro
one event comes to my mind when i was
the first time as a young mep
in dubrovnik in the city of dubravka
and we visited there the memorial center
showing the pictures of the soldiers
died
fighting defending freedom the country
but also freedom and democracy and rule
of law
and i saw the pictures i saw then the
subtitle about the names and about the
age of the people of the
soldiers died and then i read
1971 1972 and that is my first
year as well i grew up in bavaria in a
peaceful time and i always had and
and still have a lot of respect to
support for democracy in croatia
croatia is in a way
a good proof for what we have to do
today you said it because now it's a
similar situation to ukraine and moldova
for those who now stand up and fight for
our values to give them a similar
perspective that enlargement works that
we should be convinced about this model
and this approach
and this is also to uh the same towards
the western balkan that we need now a
clear
timeline i want to thank the opposition
in bulgaria today because boycott
borisov and garb voted in favor of
northern macedonia to give them a
perspective and i also want to express
towards the serbian friends that they
have to decide whether they want to join
the european union or whether they are
on the side of
russia so there is no in between anymore
um that we are
making enlargement possible we have to
improve europe
and there
you mentioned one aspect when we speak
about unanimous vote that there we have
probably different
point of views
croatia is now joining the eurozone that
means to give up sovereignty because you
have no national currency anymore but
the idea behind is to be stronger
together to be stronger together when we
vote by maturity
and the same is for foreign affairs we
have no china policy currently as
european union and this is a clear proof
that we are not capable to answer the
big challenges due to the
decision-making mechanism so that's why
you can imagine we would be happy if you
also would show up in the council to
present the idea of a convention because
we need a deepening of the european
union to make europe better stronger for
the future and croatia will contribute
to this thank you so much dear andre and
welcome thank you mr webber
i give the floor next to billiard balzan
on behalf of the s d group
[Laughter]
dear colleagues the prime minister in
every crisis crisis the poorest and the
most vulnerable suffer the most and
while some are thinking about how to put
food on the table or how to pay their
utility bills others are getting rich
energy dependence and disruptions of
production have resulted in the rising
prices
but some prices have skyrocketed
due to greed alone
taxation of winfield profits good
control over prices the fight against
growing inequalities through
redistribution of resources and the
creation of a fairer market
should be
the matter of common interest but this
will not happen by itself you as the
prime minister and your colleagues have
the responsibility to protect our
citizens i keep repeating that but maybe
you can hear it better here in brussels
in the end i want to say that joining
the eurozone is good the euro however is
not a goal it is just a means to enable
our people to live better our european
path goes further towards schengen but
it stops at the slovenian border like
our citizens i hope that we will achieve
this goal as soon as possible thank you
thank you very much miss borzan and now
on behalf of the renew group i invite
clement groschel to take the floor
thank you very much madam president
prime minister
on behalf of renew europe i'd also like
to wish you a warm welcome and ask a few
questions of you
we're pleased to see that croatia will
be joining the eurozone that's an
opportunity for croatia and for the
european union
but what will the croatian government be
doing to ensure that in this time of
great tensions
that the euro introduction won't be
abused for uh unjustified price
increases
our group of course supports
the aid to earthquake areas and we
support efficient work from the state
authorities but we also expect croatia
to do everything possible to ensure that
european funds are not abused
which has been a problem in the past
also when it comes to the rule of law
that's a fundamental issue for the
survival of the european union
so i hope that decisions of courts
will actually be respected and
implemented even when the political
class does not agree with them
then i'd like to ask you about the
migration pact
there have been reports of pushbacks and
deaths at the border
so
do these actions fulfill the standards
of european law and the standards of the
european council
schengen functions not only because
there is a freedom of movement but it
also is a
an area of common values and standards
so
we also have to
remember the relationship between
croatia and bosnia there's an issue with
nationalism here
there are nationalists who want to close
the door to eu membership for bosnia
isn't it rather a paradox okay we solve
this if we allow
bosnia
to a clear route to full membership of
the eu
surely that is in the interest not only
of the eu but also
in the interest of bosnia herzeg
governor and the croatian people
i hope
that croatia is
successful in the tourist
season and i hope that we won't have too
many traffic jams on the journey there
prime minister on behalf of the greens
welcome to the european parliament
last sunday i was debating with pierre
pollstroy vice president of the the
russian
parliament
he said that he wasn't really interested
in when ukraine become a candidate to
the eu he said it was not a problem
because ukraine won't exist
soon he called for a new uh fight in in
in russia he denounced this he's only
the reaffirmation of the brezhnev
doctrine that the limited sovereignty
saying that means by um certain
countries that can be sovereign and
others have to follow the will of these
major powers that's what we call uh
imperialism
nothing could be further from the
concept than the idea that you have just
highlighted of shared sovereignty
sovereignty which is freely shared and i
was moved
to
see after the dismembering of former
yugoslavia and say that you said quite
clearly that croatia has chosen croatian
has chosen its european vacation chosen
to renounce or perhaps not to renounce
but to share its sovereignty share its
sovereignty with uh 30 other countries
here in europe the fact that we can see
croatia joining
the eurozone and schengen and something
i'm very pleased about
i was pleased when you became a member
of the eu and i'm still convinced today
the fact that the eu is the government
system for the future
i wanted to say perhaps uh
um it's
friends who need to share their concerns
two
questions i had in relation to what is
uh going on in your country i would i'd
like to see all my mistakes to exemplary
at all points but there are two points i
wanted to mention firstly the manner in
which
european funds are allocated in your
country it falls to me to say that too
often european uh money is often um
shared on the first come first serve
rather than the narrative projects
or the
value of the european budget the value
of european projects is that we need to
be capable of doing two things together
that things we can't do on our own
now under these projects you won't be
surprised that uh as a green i talk
about the challenge of
climate change and obviously um
croatia is affected by climate change
but also you have a huge potential in
relation to renewable energy so
therefore i really would like uh croatia
to be a pioneer of this transition our
second concern i have you spoke about
accession to the schengen area
you know when we came to zagreb for the
opening of the croatian presidency we
said that we continue to receive
messages saying that there
are pushbacks at the uh borders of the
country at the time you promised us that
that would be investigated and if
anything illegal was happening
they would be dealt with but we continue
to read the messages about this
situation yes croatia should be in
schengen but not
at the price of uh um
being
being at the forefront of fortress
europe now on a personal note for over
30 years i have
a member of my family who
is
belgian and croatian you know his his
uh father came here in the 1960s and he
worked in construction but he also
always loved literature now they said
that the reality of the youth live in
20th century
um was important and it's a visceral uh
visceral connection to his uh
country and also to family values now i
know that he holds you in high esteem so
he would be proud of the fact that
you would receive this work from him
thank you mr lambert
[Applause]
i give the floor next on behalf of the
id group to kunarbek
many thanks madam president i'm not
going to speak for two or two and a half
additional minutes
maybe a few seconds more and i'm
counting on your indulgence thank you um
prime minister plankovic
minister congratulations in joining the
euro however the eurozone
has had seen close to zero if not a
negative growth
in industries uh hopelessly
beaten crushed by the usa and china
inflation driven and in switzerland it's
under three percent uh
the german saver alone
spent in 221
got 160 billion
losses
unaffordable
the popular economies are suffering
disastrously
and
the saving of the euro has been dragging
on for years uh hoping uh to find a
contradiction to article 100
of the tf eu 1
75
and
310 and 311 of the tfeu
it's a well-known phenomenon and your
thomas amoros
also from your country uh said that uh
he can only crumble on the words
individual power tried to cling to it
by giving up
but you give up your country uh you
sacrifice it for the euro
actually countries that uh actually uh
have given up on their sovereignty uh
long ago i hope that won't happen to
your country
thank you mr beck i give the flow on
behalf of the ecr to organ yuritsana
[Music]
thank you croatia
will become the 20th member of the
eurozone next year
and on this opportunity
i would like to congratulate
croatia but also
say a few words about the eurozone the
whole idea of the eurozone was to be a
group of
countries with low public debt and
healthy public finances
and they would have a common currency
from the beginning of the financial
crisis everything was transformed
the ecb has been buying
sovereign debt that has made the union
into a transfer union
since the
start of the pandemic the rules have
been forgotten about entirely debt has
been reaching ever higher levels and so
is inflation
researchers
are saying
that
countries
with their own currency have got more
solid growth
nevertheless i wish you croatia the best
of luck in joining the euro cornelia
ends
thanks a lot um mr president
prime minister
let's talk about europe the number of
things that need to change we know we're
talking about
we need
to take on the challenges and
that includes all countries of the
former yugoslavia need
to look at each other eye to eye as
equals with the eu it's high time that
we start doing that an eu that not only
presumably uh decides on who wins and
who loses but speaks out more for the
average citizens and then the eu as you
pointed out
fights poverty we're talking about food
prices energy prices and many other
things that to do that a contribution a
serious contribution needs to be made
nothing happens without freedom and
democracy in europe nothing at all it
starts
by saying to all member states including
yours and mine
to be franca
you give uh women the right to to
dispose of their own bodies
and in no way accepting or even
sabotaging their efforts uh it's
something that still hasn't been
achieved and is in jeopardy and people
at the forum
borders have to be respected uh i've
often been to your country really quite
often and it is unbearable to see how
you deal with the refugees i can't bear
to watch it
the pushback
due to the crisis time and time again
and how does that square with your
positive rose-tinted uh
look on naifa it's rather different it
doesn't add up
now of course at the croatian border for
years you fought against the taliban
explain to me
what the eu can do and what about the
afghan
refugees fleeing their country we need
to put a stop to this uh just putting
people away into little
compartmental drawers
of course we have a black book on
pushbacks of countries it's not just
croatia there are many countries in
europe who do the same so let's raise
this issue speak out and make real
change thank you
thank you miss ernst next is ivan since
thank you mr president to distinguish mr
president's recession in croatia has
reached the highest level
this is okay this is the policy that you
are pursuing
with your
party which has been sentenced before
the court
most of the parties in the croatian
parliament have voted for the sanctions
in russia so you had support of yours
party and the opposition parties into
creation parliament uh the so you
we cannot blame you for the recession
out of uh
195 countries in the world only 45
have introduced sanctions against russia
and all of them have cons consequences
however my interest is long-term policy
not just short-term policy i investigate
corruption i listen to
the citizens i report crimes and i am
building a network where your corrupted
associates
are being prosecuted one after the other
maybe you don't have uh all the
information by the croatian citizens
maybe you don't have the full truth but
just the truth that you want to present
uh bulgarian uh prime minister had
support uh by dominion uh by the media
and the proceedings against him have
lasted for 13 years brussels backed him
up
but finally he
fell because
the
the citizens of bulgaria stop this uh
why
does the eu tolerate so much corruption
in bulgaria i've been to bulgaria i've
given my contribution to the fight
against crime there and now
this prime minister is not in power and
is uh in prison mr blanco which you
should ask yourself
who will be the the last to laugh in
this situation i'll give you uh the
floor of to respond to the questions the
comments the gifts the
attributions the books that you have
received
thank you very much madam president how
much time do i have
five minutes oh okay
i will
thank you very much to uh uh president
of the european people's party and the
epp group in the parliament manfred
weber for the positive comments about
croatia's advancement and especially the
fulfillment of the criteria for joining
the eurozone when it comes to
the follow-up on the conference on on
the future of europe we shall certainly
debate it within the council
as i told you having been in the
european parliament i can completely
understand the position of the european
parliament and i will
certainly give a
constructive contribution of croatia to
what we can do to improve our
decision-making and as i said in terms
of foreign policy
we basically agree on 97 98 perhaps 99
percent of issues and then a small
margin of those dossiers where we need
more conservation and perhaps more time
to forge a compromise
to madame borzan on energy it's good
that you mentioned it now i can repeat
that we have provided a five billion
kunas package to subsidize our
households to subsidize our micro small
and medium-sized businesses to subsidize
our farmers to subsidize our fishermen
to subsidize our pensioners to lower the
vat from 25 to 5
from 13 to 5 for all those products
which are mostly used by our citizens
and thus
mitigate the effects of the spike of the
prices and we shall continue to do that
again and not only the government the
state inspectorate but also the
watchdogs in terms of consumer
protection should play their role and
strongly blacklist those who are trying
to profit in this crisis and unduly and
unjustifiably raise the prices of their
products
when it comes to mr grocer thank you for
the support for the euro
when it comes to the
eu funds and to the aid of the european
union through the eu solidarity fund for
earthquake i'm grateful here for the
commission who has helped us to
not only receive for two terrible
earthquakes in zagreb and banovina
region almost one billion euros we are
streamlining the efforts of all the
ministries in order to speed up the
process of reconstruction and also the
general comment on the use of funds we
are
using them in the best practices that
exist in the european union with all the
scrutiny and the controls that is
required
on the rule of law and pakhta sun
servanda in generally yes absolutely but
at the same time
you are aware coming from slovenia that
the unfortunate arbitration process on
the border dispute fell
and was inevitably and irretrievably
lost and denounced by the croatian
parliament because of the fraudulent
activities that
were happening between the slovenian
agent and the slovenian member of the
arbitration council so we want to solve
the bilateral border issue but not on
the basis of the process which could not
have been cleansed as if it was a
mistake of a first grader at school by
making a typing error on the alphabet
when it comes to the
migration pact we of course support it
it is part of our approach to schengen
schengen needs to be renovated upgraded
and updated but croatia should be within
uh schengen when it comes to your
comment on boston herzegovina national
politics nationalistic politics please
bear in mind
bosnia and herzegovina applied for
membership in the european union in
february of 2016 when dragon chovich the
leader of perhaps in your eyes a
nationalist party which is croatian
democratic union of bosnia and
herzegovina our sister party was
chairman of the presidency of
bosnia-herzegovina
this
the march of filing an application
was more supported by the members of
this house members croatian members of
the european parliament both from hdz
but also from social democrats and some
other friends such as at the time
romanian rapper preda than many member
states
and many member states of the european
union and we were the first one to
support the european union membership
path of bosnia and herzegovina we shall
continue to do so and continue
to extend the knowledge and
understanding of the country that is
based on the concept of one state two
entities and three constituent peoples
which should be equal none of the
constituting equals in this case kratz
edit territory of federation should not
be treated as not equal this is the only
basic simple normal decent demand and we
will stick to it
the other issue
that mr lambert's mentioned
when it comes to
the
choice of croatia for being part of the
european union i think we had this
debate
uh when you visited croatia two and a
half years ago i really enjoyed it and i
think you understood that we are doing
this of our own choice of our own free
will we shall continue to that pooling
and sharing of sovereignty is something
we support we think we are stronger in
the european union than we would have
been if we were not and therefore the
full understanding of the concept of the
european integration is something that
we fully uh
support on schengen
and the
the fact that croatian police more than
6 000 members of the croatian police is
protecting the croatia's external border
is a job which is very difficult to do a
job where there
have the total scrutiny of the entire
ministry of interior every single
complaint is being checked and verified
we have established an entirely
independent monitoring mechanism of out
of our own will in cooperation with
european commission i think that the
report of the independent monitoring
mechanism will be out
sometime next week we will be in the
process of scrutiny in the european
parliament when the opinion on croatia's
membership of schengen will be done open
to explain and to
provide arguments on any potential
allegation if there are some and we
should provide answers but generally the
schengen key we are ready the legal
standards we are ready the protection of
border we are completely ready plus we
are the country that never made a
political decision to elevate neither
walls no fences no barbed wires no with
serbia no with bosnian herzegovina no
with montenegro these are friends
neighbors with whom we should not have
physical barriers and this is something
that we can only protect by the presence
of croatian police at more than 1 300
kilometers of our external external
border
to mr beck and to mr
yuritsa
[Music]
two points croatia is a highly euros
economy
our savings our loans are basically more
than 50 60 percent in euros
uh 70 percent of tourists that visit
croatia come from eurozone are tradies
with eurozone this was the logical
choice logical follow-up of our
accession treaty we are basically
abrogating the delegation and this is
the work that we that has been done
diligently fulfilling all the criteria
with the action plan and clear opinions
of the commission and of the ecb
actually give us argument to continue to
do that for our economy euro will bring
benefits and it will not be a negative
circumstance
uh when it comes to schengen i think i
have to madame ernst answered i will
look at what you have given me when it
comes to mr sinchuch i think that
it's no surprise to the croatian public
that you come here and advocate
basically the russian position this is a
very clear you belong to one of those
political
actors who is strongly supported by the
russian actors you did this in the
croatian parliament you are doing this
now in the european parliament it's your
right but also your responsibility when
it comes to the fight against corruption
i said at the beginning of my men that
six years ago no one is immune to the
independent
work of our judicial institutions our
state prosecutor our special prosecutor
for corruption organized crime
our police they do their work
independently those who will in the
legal process be
declared as responsible for something
they will be condemned or if they are
not they will
be free just as in any other country in
europe corruption is a negative
phenomena but is not a phenomena that is
only
applicable to croatia it is
unfortunately a phenomena that exists
for many years and we are fighting it
strongly with the means with the
changing of the laws with the action
plans and with concrete cases and those
who know croatia better certainly know
that there is no whatsoever government's
influence on the work of the prosecutor
or of our judiciary or the police and it
will remain in a such manner because at
the end of the day when we joined the
european union in 2013 and you of course
didn't contribute one millimeter to for
croatia becoming a member of the
european union i did members of my party
did
uh unlike you and perhaps yours so this
is a huge difference between the two of
us we have been europeans from the first
day you have joined the train and you
are enjoying the benefits of being of
being an mep even though you obviously
do not believe neither in the european
union and haven't contributed to
croatia's european journey at all but
that is democracy i respect it and i was
very happy to be here with you today
thank you
thank you very much prime minister this
debate is now closed and we will move on
to the next debate with my colleague
ryan villand
you